what up guys welcome to the Jazz pearly
things YouTube channel today I am going
to be continuing my reaction series
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that we are going to
be notified of my daily videos today I
am going to be reacting to a
psychologist talk about how
communication is not the key to a happy
relationship
um but before I start guys make sure you
like the video on your way in and
subscribe to the channel let's get
started all right it says talking is
overrated most problems cannot be solved
with discussion talking is overrated now
this might sound strange coming from a
therapist but I'm here to tell you that
in relationships talking is overrated
but Orion isn't communication the key to
good relationships yes it is however you
have to understand that while all
talking is communication not all
communication is talking talking is good
for some things like planning Logistics
and it is absolutely terrible for other
things the most common misapplication of
this principle is assuming that if
communication is the key to good
relationships then you have to talk
about everything all the time and that
is absolute who thinks we have to talk
about everything all the time let's just
call Spade it's made here let's just
call somebody to spit women like come on
you think men want to talk about
everything all the time I'll let it go
I'll let it go not true a fair share of
effective communication is knowing what
not to talk about and understanding when
talking is useless at this point in my
life I'm convinced that I could have a
peaceful loving respectful relationship
with a woman who couldn't even speak
English
why because the point of a relationship
is not to convey semantic information
and everything essential to a
relationship can be communicated without
words I'm also a fantastic partner which
as we'll see makes a big difference
however this hasn't always been the case
I've been in some relationships in the
past where most of the relationship
consisted of talking about the
relationship what did you mean when you
said that how are we doing where is this
going and that is death why
[Laughter]
that's true though a lot of times we
talk about
why I know
you're a pissed I think I'm not the
biggest fan of therapy there is a time
and a place for talking about your
problem but it's like were they really
talking about their problems that much
back in the day no they were trying to
not get eaten by a tiger or a bear you
know they didn't really have time for
all this communication they were in the
farm or you know whatever people are
doing I agree with him I think the more
you talk about problems the more that
come because the point of a relationship
is to come together and experience each
other in the world through that
connection
and while you can do this through
talking it is almost always less
interesting and vital than doing which
would you rather do have sex or talk
about having sex
be on holiday or talk about the trip you
took six months ago talking is to doing
as imagination is to reality the former
is a pale imitation of the latter and
all other things being equal the more
time you spend talking the less time you
spend doing and that's where all the
good stuff is here's another reason why
talking is overrated how often has it
happened in your life that your partner
has said to you we need to talk
oh my gosh this is so from a man's point
of view do you know what I mean because
because we love to talk but he actually
had a point I never thought about it
like what's better talking about a
vacation or being on a vacation that's
actually a really good point yeah I do
think women we do need to talk about our
problems it's kind of how we like get
rid of stress but not with men I think
women should talk about our problems
with other women and it has to be women
that want you to win though see that's
the pro I'll tell you one thing that's
hard from woman's point of view women
often don't want you to win because a
lot of times like women friends are
jealous of each other and it becomes a
competition and all this stuff so a lot
of times like and the other issue with
young women is older women also don't
want us to win like before you could go
to your grandma's or your mother's and
I'm not saying me in specific but you
know in society right but now we got
mothers that are competing with their
daughters for the same men heck I just
had someone on the show like two days
ago that told me that he slept with a
daughter and then he slept with the mom
and he said he knows multiple people
that's happened to okay so what is my
point women do need to talk about
problems but I do think that like when
you bring too many into a relationship
gets tricky because men don't want to
hear about it and when you sat down with
this other person he or she said I need
you to know that last week when we were
having a discussion about my mother I
never felt so heard and respected and
validated in my life
to know that I'm very satisfied with
this relationship and I'm extremely
content with the way things are going
and I'm only concerned that I just might
not be able to love you any more than I
currently do okay this is why I'm not a
big fan of therapists but if they do
have the most the time they should be
men they should be met one time well
guys I went to a therapist once when I
had a relative die so they like sent me
to therapy you know how it is and and I
like went to this therapist and this is
before my YouTube days you know oh no I
went to a therapist twice in my life I
forgot about the other time once was
over a breakup all right once was over
someone died and both times I was just
sitting there thinking how stupid this
was like I was just sitting listening to
the therapist and then they would just
ask me about my problems and I'm like
well what what is this solving like that
never happens does it and why is
that because when people say we need to
talk it's because somebody has a problem
and they believe that talking is going
to resolve that problem and again this
is going to sound really weird coming
from a therapist but that is often not
the case only a small subset of problems
can really be solved by talking about
them and in many cases talking about
problems becomes a problem in and of
itself now before I go any further if
you're liking what you're hearing please
consider sending this to someone who
might benefit from its message it's Word
of Mouth referrals like this that really
help the channel to grow and you can
also hit the super thanks button and tip
me in proportion to the value you feel
you've derived from this episode I
really appreciate your support if
talking actually helps to reduce an
undesired Behavior it's generally
because the possibility of talking about
the behavior again is more aversive than
giving up the behavior itself that is
talking is a punishment Marcia Linehan
the creator of dialectical behavior
therapy understood this to be true when
a client violated his or her treatment
agreement Say by missing a group session
or arriving late she would not allow the
therapy to proceed until the behavior
was
positively discussed the client would be
eager to talk about an argument she had
with her boyfriend or a conflict he had
at work and she wouldn't let them she
would take time out of what the client
wanted to do to talk about something he
or she had done and clients generally
hated that so much that they changed
their behavior it was the punitive
component of talking that moved the
needle not the problem solving or
understanding potentialities of talking
that most people assume to be
responsible let's be honest does that
sound like like do men even say we need
to talk have you ever said that Amiri no
I don't know like I'm just thinking like
this guy
oh this is so from like a guy's point of
view he's right though like I do think
as women we need to stop bringing men so
many of our problems I guess that begs
the question if as women we have a
problem and we really feel like we need
to talk about it do we a ignore it until
goes away do we be go to another woman
about the problem or C go to the man
about the problem what do you think of
Mary the B is go to a woman about it
yeah but here yeah and then see okay
then then you go to the guy you go to
the woman first you see but then this is
the issue we get into is if the women
want you to win this is why you can't
have divorced women around your friends
or around your girl because women
influence other women so much so should
they if I was reading this these court
documents from uh like this one guy in
jail or I'm not in jail and um that came
in for an interview about child custody
and he told me that he had um evidence
of his like girlfriend conspiring with
this other chick against him and it was
crazy because this girl will be like we
had an argument and then she was like I
can't believe his coercive controlling
you
to the extent so careful what women you
go with to with your problems you gotta
analyze them do they want you to win
do you think your dad wants to hear I do
go to my dad more than I should but then
it's like the men they're like what what
yeah well that's what I'm saying it's
supposed to be the mothers right but the
problem is we have so many women that
were single mothers and didn't stay
married so it's like you're not and a
lot of times like you know misery loves
company so do those mothers really want
their daughters to be in happy healthy
relationships some do but you know you
need to talk works it's because it's
punitive and punishments reduce the
frequency of behavior but should you
really be punishing your partner it's
generally not a very good idea for a
number of reasons in the first place to
the extent that it works it increases
the power imbalance in a relationship
why for the simple reason that
punishments can really only issue from
the more powerful to the less powerful
so the more you employ punishment the
more powerful you become and the less
powerful your partner becomes which
isn't usually sustainable as it leads to
resentment on both sides punishers are
resentful because they increasingly feel
parentified and critical and punishes
are resentful because they increasingly
feel infantilized and criticized wow
that was such a good point this guy's
very insightful because the more okay
the more and let's be honest he's
talking about men and women he's not
saying it but he so is he's he's
basically saying the women always
criticize the men and then the women get
more power than the men because because
like then the woman's controlling their
relationship because the man is avoiding
these behaviors because the woman like
they don't want to talk about it and
it's just more of a headache oh my gosh
I hear that all the time from guys
actually now that I think about it what
a drag after all good relationships are
about enjoying who your partner is not
about changing them into who you want
them to be
now when do people feel like they need
to talk when somebody was disrespectful
or somebody was lazy or somebody was
irresponsible or somebody was
inconsiderate or somebody was
withholding
Etc unpopular opinion but talking will
not fix any of those things talking will
not make a disrespectful person
respectful or a lazy person productive
or a irresponsible person responsible
and insisting on talking about these
yeah I thought about this actually
um yeah because of a certain Shores
debate you know it it goes like in
marriage you're supposed to love people
for who they are not what you want them
to be and I think that's like a big
switch that like a lot of women have
it's like you can't change the person
like that that's who you marry you know
it's who you married and I I learned
this lesson from my aunt once because
she was saying how she used to like get
so frustrated at her husband for like
being messy or whatever and she just
learned that like to see that as a way
that she was showing him that she loved
him and seemed to you know help is
really a kind of intolerance for the
partner you chose
the way to solve these problems is not
by talking but by being respectful
productive responsible considerate and
generous
if you are a good partner and you choose
people who are also good partners there
really won't be much to talk about this
is why I believe that I could have an
excellent relationship with someone who
doesn't speak my language I know how to
be a good partner and I know how to
recognize people who know how to be good
partners all the things that I'm looking
for in a relationship kindness loyalty
tenderness sensuality patience
generosity positivity prioritization
connection do not need words in fact
they can all be communicated wordlessly
in actions and in a general attitude
toward life
I have plenty of people to talk to if I
feel the urge to do so
I don't need a woman to talk to I need a
woman for other things the fact of the
matter is is there is little need to
talk about most problems because the
vast majority of problems spontaneously
remiss which is to say they tend to take
care of themselves
you don't have to talk about every
little thing you don't have to process
every uncomfortable emotion that you
experience throughout your week these
things come and go
on the other hand talking about a
problem enshrines that in the memory of
the relationship such that something
that could have been a temporary issue
becomes a permanent fact the only issues
that really need to be discussed are
deal breakers and there are really these
are really just two minute conversations
if a problem is so bad that it would
destroy the relationship all by itself
then give people the option to choose
between the problem or the relationship
and move on with your life it's not easy
but it really is that simple and that's
what I have to say for the time being I
liked him that's actually one of the
most base psychologists I've watched
a while ago what'd you think you like
him he definitely was he was definitely
talking about men and women though he
didn't say it he was like your partner
but I think that's actually a really
good point that he can have a
relationship with someone he couldn't
even understand
because a lot of personality traits he's
right okay but let me know what you guys
think in the comments like the video on
your way out subscribe to the channel
you already know the deal and I'll talk
to you next time